[Music]
oh okay so cuz we're gonna introduce
herself as I'm Jessie and I'm a
london-based presenter and I use
Instagram to spread a body confidence
message I'm poppy and I have a fashion
line called pop and Sookie I'm heavier
DaSilva I'm a blogger and I love to talk
about makeup I love your Instagram aha
okay so we're going to talk about
beautifully better feeling naturally
confident in our own skin or creating
that natural glow with makeup I wish I
could have bear makeup the whole time
when I see women with no makeup and they
look incredible I'm like wow dreamers
you got s yeah I love being beautifully
bare it just doesn't happen that much
I'm the same I feel most beautiful when
I'm just strip back I have no makeup on
and I'm just comfortable in being that
and it's taken me so long to get to that
point and actually I have been using my
visit just to the massage I get puffy
really easily when I'm traveling good to
traveling oh gosh she got on a plane you
get off and honestly it's not a nice
like a marshmallow you look like a
marshmallow eventually but you do makeup
tutorials obviously habibur and you talk
about creating that look with makeup if
I want a natural look without using too
much makeup I always tend to go for
concealer and then I'll just go over the
rest of my skin with a little bit of
powder and just put on a little bit of
shimmer and that's I'm good to go with
my skin isn't it funny how now we see on
social media what everyone thinks is
beautiful thinking that you need to
build up your face you're thinking that
you need to wear these beautiful clothes
the first thing you do every day is go
on social media our daily habit has been
to go and like everybody else's life
Mars yeah and you begin to compare your
life to other people undermine your own
life the heirs of what you see online
think I should be doing that yeah I
should I should is the I should I must
comparison is the thief of all joy it's
so easy for us to feel so stressed
around beauty and
no I have really had to make stressful
times where you just don't feel right
and you can choose whether Instagram or
social media makes you happy
or makes you sad like I always say
cleanse your social media if you're
scrolling through and you're like I feel
awful
then you're following the wrong people
important sometimes to remember what you
think beauty is and beauty does not only
mean what you want someone looks like on
the outside there's so many levels of
beauty I want to move on to how we feel
with hair removal you go long-term don't
you long-term hair removal is probably
the best thing I ever did for myself so
I usually wax and it is so painful and
you get here and you know the pain and
I've traced so many different waxes but
I'm definitely looking for an
alternative I've been using the Lumia
and it is a dream honesty doesn't hurt
it's so easy to do and after three
treatments you're 92% less hair that it
is amazing it's so effective and it's so
you don't need to worry about it anymore
as long as soon as you've you've sorted
it out that's it so what's amazing with
the Lumiere it has a skin tone
recognition sensor so basically I'm
gonna test yours so we turn it on say
Tracy it's gorgeous
unloved Rose God okay so we're gonna
test your skin its height and it will
tell you the number okay so you can use
number five which is the most intense on
the Phillips Lumiere and then you
basically just press the tick the app
reminds you when to do it so every two
weeks it pops up on your phone dreamy
isn't it amazing amazing love it love it
hello baby it's changed my life some of
the topics that we touched on are so
important but people actually don't talk
about them and I think the more that we
took and the more that we share our own
journeys the more it helps people
especially young girls that are
struggling and looking through social
media thinking that that is real life a
beauty is a lot more than out of you
this also about what on the inside we
sometimes overlook for other people and
the way they behave because of how they
look like on the outside it's really
lovely to be in a scenario where we can
talks openly about it and I find out
packs because I love hearing other
people's tips tricks and secrets
[Music]